[Musica]
da diversi anni ormai i nostri rapporti
umani conoscono una grande metamorfosi
come se stessero this incarnando e
avessero cambiato di valenza
assumendone da una più fisica materica
reale una nuova diversa immateriale ai
limiti delle vane scienza e della
volatilità
quanti di voi se ne sono accorti e se sì
quando
l'attimo cruciale in cui le nostre
relazioni hanno cominciato a
smaterializzarsi
ci è sfuggito e ora ne percepiamo la
vulnerabilità molte sono appesantite
frantumate altri sono allentate è molto
più superficiali
molti dei nostri scambi si sono fatti
eterei perché quasi sempre nell'etere
virtuali
con messaggi mail ci comunichiamo cose
pratiche ma anche molto altro
l'amore il disamore con chat e messaggi
litighiamo ci avviciniamo
sempre più vicini sempre più lontani ed
altro stadi come possibilità via via più
incorporea
destinatario di una comunicazione
che comunica e trasmette stati d'animo
ma in modo talmente rapido che molto
spesso non oltrepassa il tempo
dell'enunciazione
costruire tessere le nazioni
in uno schema del genere una sfida là
dove molte volte i dialoghi si svolgono
in assenza degli occhi dell'altro delle
sue mani
dell'aura che ciascuno proietta intorno
a sé quando c'è c'è fisicamente in
presenza
è il risultato di questo connubio tra
onnipresenza delle parole è invece e
progressiva assenza dei corpi e che le
parole
veicolano si sentimenti pulsioni ma
nello stesso tempo creano distanza la
disegnano la fanno
distanze prossemica
molto a che fare con una questione di
distanze di vicino e lontano dei
rapporti umani
umani e prima ancora animali conoscete
forse l'apologo dei porcospini
schopenhauer un crocchio di porcospini
che per causa del freddo sente l'impulso
di stare vicini stretti stretti
ma presto quello stare così accanto deve
finire perché con gli aculei si stanno
giungendo
disturbando facendosi del male
forse trovate anche voi ogni prossimità
entra in crisi quando raggiunge un certo
limite quando sconfina
anna akhmatova poetava c'è un confine
nell'intesa umana e si riferiva al
confine nel significato stesso di
confine per quel margine di separatezza
che crea per quell'impronta che come una
crepa incide su ogni intesa quel quella
separatezza che ogni intesa porta in sé
con sé come un marchio questo vuoto e
spazio di separatezza e separazione che
ci allontana in questi tempi più che mai
né troppo insieme né troppo poco insieme
sembra essere la prossemica di ogni
relazione
né con te né senza di te cantava ovidio
parlando dell'amore anche la poesia di
anna akhmatova parla d'amore
confine nell'intesa umana e non lo varca
ardore né passione seppure nel silenzio
si fondano le labbra e il cuore si
franca d'amore neppure l'amicizia può
varcarlo né anni di alta e fiammeggiante
gioia quando l'anima è libera e aliena
dal vento consumarsi del piacere
chi vuole raggiungerlo e folle se lo
tocca e parole per l'impianto ora sai
perché non senti più il mio cuore
battere sotto la tua mano calda
ogni prossimi si trova davanti a un
dilemma essere insieme ma non riuscire a
starci insieme e nel panorama strano il
nuovo in cui molti dei nostri rapporti
si trovano a vagare disorientati come
sul bilico di un precipizio
quel dilemma sembra essersi necrotizzato
cerchiamo gli altri ma non riusciamo a
raggiungere gli altri perché la loro
fisicità si è allontanata non sono corpi
piuttosto l'atmosfera di parole digitate
su tablet non sono l'atmosfera di quei
corpi tutto ciò che con il nostro corpo
il suo alfabeto le posture i gesti le
cose che non riusciamo a trasmettere
essendoci con la plasticità e la materia
di cittá del corpo piuttosto
degli altri ascoltiamo le voci ne
vediamo i volti sui monitor
né scorriamo dei siti internet dei
profili social dei tweet like post e
quant'altro
7 sorrisi flute di champagne e fiori
cuori
lune piene mezze lune gli emoticon sono
diventati il veicolo della nostra
socialità
recente e attuale
non fosse che gli altri quando poi li
incontriamo adesso facciamo fatica ad
abbracciarli
anche i baci sulle guance sono rapidi
sfuggenti
siamo tutti più irrigiditi impettiti
rispetto a prima
e con disorientamento ricordiamo e
abbiamo nostalgia di un'altra epoca
precedente dove la prossemica più
ravvicinata ed era un ben più facile
immaginare di sconfinare quei limiti
tutto questo che dico è stato
moltiplicato in modo esponenziale dalla
pandemia dalla paura del contagio dai
look dow delle chiusure e nella chiusura
e nella sensazione di stare confinati
ancora una volta tutta una questione di
confini e come un po fossimo diventati
tutti i porcospini
inclini a un vicino lontano che
comprende né con te né senza di te che
sembra essere la regola di ogni
prossemica di ogni redazione
adesso la distanza è come se si
definisce da sola anche quando non
vorremmo si definisce anzi subito molto
chiara netta invalicabile
siamo
soli fisicamente molto più soli ma anche
più selettivi più radicali più
intransigenti nelle redazioni
soli ma anche stanchi profondamente
stanchi di tanta
disincarnati one
e bisognosi come saremo e siamo di
problemi che nuove
ci ritroviamo a fantasticare forse
capita anche a voi di immaginare come
sarebbe libero e liberatorio provare di
nuovo a valicare quei limiti ritrovare
prossimità vicinanza fisicità il
contatto le mani gli abbracci forti
quando senti addirittura il battito del
cuore dell'altro mentre ti stringe forte
e il sudore i bagliori negli occhi e
tutto ciò che è carne carnalità una
bella pacca sul culo la fisicità dei
corpi
grande depressione e di ogni grande
crisi che si sia attraversata il segno
e quel buio è finito tante volte che si
risveglia desiderio non necessariamente
il desiderio erotico però un desiderio
di contatto di fisicità di vicinanza
alla fine della dittatura dei colonnelli
in grecia il grande poeta di anni se
rizzo che per causa di quella dittatura
aveva scontato duri anni di un'assurda
prigione compone una raccolta di poesie
dal titolo erotica ed editori italiano
nicola crocetti scelse quella raccolta
come primo titolo della sua casa
editrice
uscì prima in italia che in grecia è una
poesia della raccolta si intitola parola
carnale ne leggiamo solo qualche verso
tutti i corpi che ho toccato che ho
visto che ho preso che ho sognato tutti
sono addensati nel tuo corpo o tu
carnale di ottima nel grand simposio dei
greci 6 l'oblio assoluto se il recordo
assoluto
6 la non incrinata fragilità fa giorno o
carnale di ottima tu che mi hai
partorito che ho partorito e ora che
partoriamo azioni e poesie che usciamo
nel mondo
davvero non scordare quando vai al
mercato di comprare mele in abbondanza
non quelle d'oro delle esperidi ma
quelle grosse rosse che quando affondi
nella polpa croccante i tuoi splendidi
denti resta impresso come un eternità
sui libri pieno di vita il tuo sorriso
dice bene rizzo è tempo di partorire
azioni e poesie di tornare ai nostri
corpi perché da loro e dalla loro
fisicità concreta vera carnale che può
inaugurarsi un'epoca nuova
un'epoca con te e con te vicino regolata
da confini dilatati ma che permettano la
condivisione dello spazio
senza pungersi ma senza ignorarsi forse
possiamo cominciare tutti insieme grazie
[Applauso]